la mairesse de Rouyn-Noranda,
Diane Dallaire.
Bonsoir Mme Dallaire.
- Bonsoir.
- Monsieur Boileau a bien prie
soin de souligner à plusieurs
reprises que tout ça est
progressif.
e première cible dans
l'éventualité qu'on atteigne,
qu'on le sait pas, la norme de 3
ng par mètre cube.
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez?
- En fait, c'est une belleavanc.
C'est une étape importante vers
l'atteinte éventuelle du 3 ng.
Alors, on savait qu'il pouvait y
avoir des délais, ou des cibles
peut-être intermédiaires.
Mais, le discours nous a quand
même rassuré, même si on sait
qu'elles restent plusieurs
étapes.
Ce qu'on nous dise que le 15 ng,
les experts de la santé publique
de l'INSPQ nous ont dit que
c'est un seuil...
- Sécuritaire.
- Oui, de protectipour
les jeunes enfants et les femmes
enceintes.
Peut-être de citoyens plus
vulnérables.
Ça nous rassure, mais on sait
que ce n'est qu'une étape vers
te du 3 ng.
- On sait que les gens de rouet
sont mobilisés dans cette
affaire.
Chez vous, des gens qui disent
qu'on se sent comme des cobayes
s d'un seuil à l'autre.
Peut-être aussi une absence de
clarté tantôt échéancier.
Il n'y aurait pas un effort
supplémentaire pour être fait
là-dessus?- En fait, ce que je s
c'est que c'est une étape
importante.
Ce qu'on a demandé formellement
c'est que la fonderie vise les
normes non seulement pour
l'arsenic mais pour l'ensemble
des métaux.
- Oui le plomb et le cadmium
notamment.
- Oui, Niquet le plomb et le
cadmium.
Bref, nous allons voir, c'est
sûr qu'il va y avoir un dépôt du
plan d'action, des rencontres
aussi que nous aur
l'environnement.
Clairement, nous allons demander
au ministre de l'environnement
que la recommandation de la
santé publique qui a été donnée
aujourd'hui fasse
l'autorisation ministérielle.
C'est sûr et certain qu'il reste
des étapes pour vraiment
connaître effectivement les
cibles intermédiaires et les
échéanciers.
Parce que, c'est la santé de nos
ens, on l'ens, on l'ens, on l'es
de plus de buts, il y a urgence.
- Urgence d'agir, pas de doute
là-dessus.
Dans quelle mesure, ce sont dese
dîtes, dans quelle mesure vous
faites confiance en cette
compagnie qui chapeaute la
fonderie?
Dans quelle mesure ils sont de
bonne foi?
Et dans quelle mesure selon
vous, au fond de vous-même,
qu'ils peuvent mettre les
efforts nécessaires pour que
finalement on atteigne cet
objectif?
- Vous savez , je l'ai dit
depuis le début, la fonderie
c'est une entreprise pour moins
de revendeurs, la santé c'est la
priorité.
C'est là qu'on est rendu.
- Mezzana l'a pas été de pendant
des décennies.
Vous comprendrez qu'il y a de la
méfiance.
- En fait, je vous dirai que les
récentes données qui nous ont
été présentées par la santé
publique nous parlait
d'incidence de cancer du poumon
plus élevé.
Espérance de vie moins élevée
qu'ailleurs au Québec.
Des bébés de petits pois, c'est
quand même récemment qu'on a
eu... qu'on nous a informé de
C'est là peut-être que les
demandes se sont accélérées.
Maintenant, on demeure confiantt
apportées.
Je le disais tout à l'heure des
communiqués de l'entreprise qui
dit vouloir présenter un plan
d'action d'importance majeure.
Et investir des sommes qui
seront annoncées, mais c'est ce
qu'on attend, le plan d'action
de l'entreprise.
Je vous dirai que nous demeurons
très vigilants.
Comme je l'ai dit, c'est une
belle avancée, mais ce n'est pas
terminé, il reste beaucoup
d'étapes avant l'autorisat
ministérielle.
- Les citoyens seront vigilants
également.
On rappelle que certains
spécialistes - il la sirène
d'alarme dans les